cuál es la pendiente en la línea que
contiene los puntos 7 medios menos 19
cuartos y menos dos tercios 57 octavos
en este caso voy a resolver el problema
empleando una fórmula pues será la
intención de quienes escribieron el
problema en primer lugar pero realmente
les recomiendo que piensen que significa
la fórmula en vez de utilizarla
ciegamente la idea es que la fórmula
debe de reflejar el hecho de que la
pendiente es una medida de la
inclinación de una recta así que
supongamos que tenemos dos puntos x 1,1
x2 de 2
entonces la pendiente de la recta que
pasa por estos dos puntos que se denota
por m va a ser igual a la diferencia
entre las coordenadas 10 pero con un
orden específico si empezamos con 2
entonces le quitamos 10 1 y como
empezamos con de 2
entonces en el denominador tenemos que
empezar con x2 entonces empezamos con x
2 y le quitamos x 1 y esta pequeña
fórmula nos da el valor de la pendiente
de la recta que pasa por esos dos puntos
podemos elegir a este punto como nuestro
punto x 1,1 y lo que estamos diciendo es
que x1 va a valer siete medios y uno va
a valer menos 19 cuartos entonces lo que
estoy haciendo es asignando los valores
a x 1 y c 1
y digamos que este segundo punto es x 2
de 2
entonces x 2 es menos dos tercios y de
257 octavos 57 octavos y ahora
simplemente tengo que aplicar la fórmula
de la pendiente así que la pendiente de
la recta que pasa por esos dos puntos es
igual a de 2 que vale 57 octavos
57 octavos menos de 1 que es menos 19
cuartos
ahora todo eso tiene que ir / / x2 que
vale menos dos tercios menos dos tercios
menos x1 y x1 vale siete medios y ahora
viene la parte más complicada del
problema que es realmente reducir esta
fracción en realidad hay muchos modos de
hacerlo quizás lo usted lo pueden hacer
de otro modo pero yo simplemente lo voy
a hacer lo más directo posible entonces
primero voy a trabajar con el numerador
y voy a poner esas dos fracciones con
denominador común que es 8
quizá sería mejor idea utilizar los
mismos colores que antes así que tengo
57 octavos y ahora tengo que escribir
menos 19 cuartos con denominador 84 por
268 así que pueda ser menos 19 por 2 y
me da menos 38 y ahora trabajo con el
denominador las fracciones del
denominador tiene denominador común 6
como 3 por 2 6 entonces menos 2 x 2
es menos 4 ya eso le restó mis 7 medios
7 medios escritos con denominador 6 es
igual a como 2 por 13 6 7 por 3 21
entonces es igual a 21 sextos así que
ahora simplemente tengo que reducir todo
esto y esto se convierte en 57 octavos
menos menos 38 octavos y como menos por
menos es más esto se convierte en 57
octavos más 38 octavos que se convierte
en
95 95 entre 8 así que tenemos 95 entre 8
y eso va dividido entre menos 4 en 36
menos 21 entre 6 - 4 - 21 es menos 25
dividido entre 6 así que tenemos 95
entre 8 dividido entre menos 25 entre 6
esto es lo mismo que 95 octavos
multiplicado por el recíproco de menos
25 sextos y ese recíproco es
sencillamente menos 6 entre 25
y por ejemplo podemos simplificar un
poco esta operación 6 y 8 son divisibles
entre 2 así que esto se convierte en un
3 y esto se convierte en un 4 al
cancelar el 2 y ahora si no nos libramos
de hacer la operación así que tengo 95
por 3 y 95 por 3 es poco menos de 300 es
285 un mejor escriba que al ladito 285
dividido entre 4 por 25 es esta sencilla
4 por 25 x 100 así que el resultado es
que la pendiente de la recta es 285 y
espérense se me olvidó este menos aquí
tengo un menos que está escondido
así que de primer lo corrijo 95 x menos
3 3 285 negativo dividido entre 4 por 25
entre 100 así que no está pendiente es
menos 285 entre 100 se podría
simplificar un poco cancelando algunos
cincos por ahí yo les sugeriría que
realicen la simplificación de la
pendiente del valor de la pendiente y
que graphic en estos dos puntos en un
plano coordenada y atrás en la línea
recta para que de ese modo bien quede
dos menos de uno realmente es el cambio
en la coordenada ye y que x 2 - x 1
simplemente es el cambio en la
coordenada x otro buen ejercicio es
tomar este punto como el x 1 de 1 y este
como el x 2 de 2 y verán que les da el
mismo resultado
en el ejemplo que nosotros hicimos
tomamos este menos este y lo dividimos
entre este menos este si los
intercambiamos entonces tendríamos este
menos esté dividido entre este menos
este la clave está en que el primero en
el numerador y el primero en el
denominador tienen que ser coordenadas
del mismo punto así que estas dos vienen
del mismo punto y estas dos vienen del
mismo punto así que bueno esos son
algunos ejercicios para que practiquen